think he's as quick on the mouse over
the board blitz he's very very good yeah
we've seen him do well in the tour on uh
in blitz as well but magnus is maybe
another level okay so let's go back to
the players will he drop his bishop back
and go for the draw
or is he going to play pawn takes pawn
and go for the win under two minutes i
guess the longer he thinks about it the
more likely he is to go for the druish
yeah what do you think simon well he's
gone for a draw yeah
and i think the tournament situation i
mean a draw they both qualify it's it's
i mean okay i mean i think
david would have definitely gone for the
win there no matter what but i mean it
is kind of sensible as well with two
minutes yeah i would have gone for the
win and then lost
so
that's why ding is the world number two
yeah i mean it
it's a practical choice isn't it and i
think they'd be shaking hands soon but
in terms of the tournament situation it
makes sense uh to play it safe but you
can can he still so he can still go pawn
takes point
i thought it would be a draw
automatically now but this is his last
chart now it is there we go third time
we've seen that position it is a draw a
draw between world number one and world
the number two